one year ago an elderly man and a young
woman were found on a bench barely
conscious in Salisbury in England now
the pair was later identified as Sergey
is crippled a former Russian spy and his
daughter Julia crippled they had been
poisoned by another agent known as Navi
chalk
a chemical that paralyzes muscles
including those in the heart and the
wounds needed for breathing
now the chemical was manufactured in
Russia in the 1980s but this was the
first time that the chemical agent was
used in Europe and all fingers pointed
at Russia now who else was affected by
this attack Detective Sergeant Nick
Halley who attended to the screw house
walls was also poisoned and although he
survived he lost his home his car and
his possessions he was allegedly
compensated for this loss he resumed his
post in early 2019 now months after the
first poisoning which happened in March
2018
Charlie Rowley and his partner Don
staggers a mother of three also came in
contact with a perfume bottle used for
the poison attack they found the bottle
in a beam which had a modified nozzle
now Charlie tried to put it together and
don't sprayed the content on her wrists
Don succumbed to the poison well Charlie
survived UK officials claimed Russia was
behind the attack one because of the
chemical element as was supported by
findings from the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons but more
compelling was the CCTV footage showing
the two suspects Alexander Petrov and
Ruslan
basarov walking around Salisbury here's
what UK prime minister Theresa May said
it is now clear but mr. scribble and his
daughter were poisoned with a
military-grade nerve agent of a type
developed by
this is part of a group of nerve agents
known as Nova chop based on the positive
identification of this chemical agent by
world leading experts at the defense
Science and Technology Laboratory at
Porton Down our knowledge that Russia
has previously produced this agent and
would still be capable of doing so
Russia's record of conducting
state-sponsored assassinations and our
assessment that Russia views some
defectors as legitimate targets for
assassinations the government has
concluded that it is highly likely that
Russia was responsible for the act
against Sergey and Giulio scripta now
the two suspects were later identified
by Belen cut an investigative agency dr.
Alexander Myshkin and as Coronel Anatoly
chapito two members of the GRU those
names have since been confirmed by
British officials and just recently they
have released the alias of a third
suspect now Russia has of course denied
these claims and Putin actually
responded basically there was no any
serious must-win affirmance here were
super huge wolves - yes debatable we
were just a little conditioner forgive
Leoben a mystic attach Avedon fact about
another no not at Ponemah the Bureau of
tourism near mid-pack exists an external
image in each totally but controlling
military version still a tapir were Mia
Patricia Nick Turner partner officially
at this deal nos we have is a just
oxygen but why would Russia use Navi
choke poison if it could be traced back
to them on the show today I have a
Michael Kaufman a fellow at the clean
and Institute
Woodrow Wilson international center in
Washington now his work focuses on
security issues in Russia and the former
Soviet Union welcome very much Michael
Kaufman to this show
could you begin by explaining to us why
would run
knowing that this poison would be traced
back to them use it for a former Russian
spy they do that it could be traced back
to them I mean the whole idea of that
attack was as a demonstration and the
poison they chose was both meant to be
a spectacular form of attack similar to
the case of Litvinenko back in 2006 who
was poisoned with polonium a radioactive
substance and it was done intentionally
such that people would know that the
Russians did it and that they would
understand why they did it potentially
releases back and dual nature to it one
of course the poison kills curveball and
send a message to other former Russian
spies and agents and various sort of
enemies of the Russian regime that many
of which take up residence in London and
another one naturally to the British
government that there are consequences
to the British government for harboring
these individuals now a bit of
background on scruple in 2004 December
he was arrested by Federal Security
Service agents on suspicion of treason
he had been a double agent sharing
Russian secrets with the mi6 that is the
British military intelligence for almost
a decade now in 2006 he was sentenced to
13 years in prison but he did not have
his full sentence in 2010 one of the
biggest and prominent spy swap in
decades Russia and the u.s. agreed to
swap 10 Russia and sleepers let's agents
who haven't been activated with four
prisoners that Russia had accused of
being double agents now this was done in
Austria but one of the prisoners but is
Serge a is crippled ended up in the UK
and he led a pretty quiet life until
this poisoning is there something that
we are me seeing Michael yeah he didn't
lead a pretty quiet life like with
Venango many people suspect that he was
flying around and he was working with
british intelligence to help him
identify Russian Russian connections to
organized crime which is what Litvinenko
was doing though British intelligence
some Spanish security services identify
poles of money and linkages between
martial organizations and marshal
organized crime where they were parking
their money in Spain maybe will suspect
that script will do is doing the same
thing and it's important understand that
Russia is a country runs off of it
informal rules in patronage networks
right and the way people know that
somebody has broken a rule rules are
unstated they're not written down
anywhere per se is by things that happen
to them right and what happened in the
case of scruple is typically does not
necessarily go after people that they've
traded back a spy swap is a spy swap
right but in their minds there's an some
inherent understanding or rule that
scruple was supposed to retire and live
out a quiet life in the UK and quite
possibly he was not doing that and the
reason they conducted such a public
attack was to send a signal to one
anybody in Russia who would be
interested in betraying or some talk
just to suggest to them that you're not
going to be traded back to a comfortable
life in the UK right you might actually
be killed and and to to make it clear no
to other people who have been traded
back to previous swap so these are the
consequences if you continue basically
cooperating with foreign intelligence
even after you're traded but the fact
that the poison that was used there nava
choke is say to be more powerful than
the VX for example would it be enough
than to just give a hint of what could
happen or why when they killed by this
poison if it's experts who were who were
working with it well one said to me it's
phenomenal how many things are said to
be by British security that has never
had or handled no be shocked but here's
the truth there are many different kinds
of another chart and with this kind of
chemical weapons are actually pretty
difficult to apply in us one of the big
challenges with chemical weapons why
people tend not to use them in general
is because they're pretty difficult to
use they're not totally all that
effective and you can easily make a
mistake and how you mix them put it
together from what I understand in this
case the the nerve agent they were using
they mixed it and they applied it to a
surface and it's quite likely that the
individual
of all i'm thankfully for screwball
didn't mix it correctly and applied
correctly and that's why I didn't kill
script ball ultimately instead I mean it
would have probably if emergency
services were not called to find him on
that banks here's the truth there's a
fair chance he might have died together
to get those daughter but quite quite
likely they botched the operation
shortest it no not actually wait likely
they botched operation it's not as
simple to use as it may sound and and
the truth of it is that it's also very
possible that they smuggled to them to
the UK as a series of binary agents that
they had to mix together and that they
didn't do it correctly I mean that's the
yeah that's the that's the most
straightforward and the most likely
answer in a scenario as to how toxic and
poisonous it is well some aren't some or
not that's not necessarily the case this
is a type of nerve agent of which there
are many different variants so British
security services may have well
overstated their case is killing or
targeting enemy enemies in foreign
countries part of Russia's security
policy yeah it is absolution that such
and such person is our target is it who
is it in the government is it in the
military so decisions on these kind of
reactions involve target assassination
or ultimately proved at the very top of
the state by the president and the
leader of Russia who all knows later who
has been for twenty years are you
claiming that Russia is behind the
attack
I think everyone's claiming that I mean
we're a year down the line I think that
I'm not sure there's anybody on earth
that's not claiming verses behind the
attack except for Russia now the UK
accusing Russia led to a diplomatic spat
reminiscent of the Cold War scores of
Russian diplomats were expelled from
countries such as Britain u.s. gem
the Netherlands and more and Russia
retaliated by expelling diplomats of all
the countries that had expelled theirs
now we have stay or rather you have said
that Russia is the first person who is
suspected or the state that is suspected
of wanting to kill him but who else you
have said that screw Paulo had tribes
well he was expected to be a retired spy
but who so who else would have wanted to
kill him
skeeball I mean British intelligence
worked back effectively 3jo agents from
Russia's main intelligence Directorate
basically the general staff Shubham had
entered the country and had conducted
this operation the weekend went back so
it's not I'll be frank it's not really a
mystery as to what happened when it
happened who did it or how they did it
these facts have been well established
and pieced together so I'm not really
sure who else might have wanted to kill
them to be honest it doesn't make too
much sense to me it's pretty pretty
pretty clearly worked out case in fact
we not only know the intelligence agents
who did it but we know their background
we know their entire story we know a
whole host of faxes to their association
with marshal military intelligence the
comedy that was their passport numbers
and the fact that all these employ
states are issued at a similar series of
passport numbers and their dossiers is
actually very little surprisingly very
little bit still about this case this is
a very long force operation by the
Russian state where they really did want
people to know I mean they wanted to get
caught the whole point was to send a
message it was not meant to be a clever
really a clandestine operation
thank you very much for your time
Michael Michael Kaufman is a fellow at
the Keenan Institute wardro Wilson
international center in Washington DC
and his work focuses on security issues
in Russia and the former Soviet Union
specializing in defense and military
analyses thank you so much for your time
Michael thanks thanks very many program
that's it from me until next time
goodbye